simple on the high ground with the
Caesar surely he's gonna get taken out
orders a gift he could pick up an APA
this might not be over yet
there's no Hitler they've gotta go far
simple the second one they have to keep
going they've got a charge forward it
misses the job straight me now after
five seventy waiting the pair of short
B's read touching the bomb already gun
to peak holding it now and there is it
all right learner's Harriet chorus
trolleys
well guys that's a wrap for the final
csgo major of the year and once again a
straw 'less are on top of the
counter-strike world they won on the
back of dominating discipline incredible
team play and of course individual
brilliance now over the course of this
major we got two and a half weeks of
nearly non-stop counter-strike action we
felt chills down our spine watching some
incredible place and of course we heard
the crowd at SSC Arena in Wembley make
their voices heard cheering on hometown
heroes smoo yeah and death there really
were just so many incredible plays from
this major and we've distilled them all
into a neat little package just for you
but only the best of the best
now let's get things started with the
kind of plays that make you want to spam
back in the chat tis easy boys they're
in no-man's land
very typical squad the hell was that
spoon yuck this is you're taking this
off fighting how is that a frag how is
this real life that is beautiful
yeah that's dust us good mechanics does
it use Ukraine dude doesn't make
anything against Ike not a theater Vida
next time see Nico
Oh
Computers 9 that was a great idea and
between phase you have to admire how
much pressure there keeping on Australis
at the moment oh my god that was such a
big shot if he dies there this is Ron
this is lost that Haiti is hoping that
everybody would wait what a mom can be a
great choice that's the reason why the
Scout here could be quite strong if
Seekers able to get a couple connections
Wow
what on earth was that James do you
explain oh no sorry enjoyed without a
cane is a problem finally though buddy
will remove that problem but death he's
seen a decent discussing things with
this Scout the bomb still needs to get
planted it's about to pounce on the
people but that kill from Nikko was so
critical the hole where
what is that one p1 now father's beep
thought its decode versus walk sick
where is DK well we've spotted here Oh
what what does that was he just like set
in the movie already earth all that
through the wall what's going on Oh
Riley there
they can't even hide the smiles and they
when they like that to show yeah they're
just so happy to be here so
that will be a nice prank the pop flash
oh the timing is absolutely perfect
they refuse to give it a home with the
ball bank with the bombs I didn't notice
that that's my god
alright then it's a depressing song ok
genuinely good mood
if I like oh good night so now it's up
to [ __ ] I think it's to wear for now
it's a 1vs1
let's run the JW's on the a side and
they've got the shotgun that gives his
position away I mean that's the trouble
here or apparently he's absolutely fine
they're jumping the shotgun prevailed I
need to see that chakra device how did
he die the bomb at a fresh smoke was
down at CT spawn did he get it yeah most
of it well this was to play no oh my god
that's how he denies the plum that's
insane map alright guys those were some
pretty incredible borderline suspicious
plays but it's not all about being
flashy oh no it's about getting the W
and what better way and when you do it
solo so with that in mind here are the
best clutches from this past major feel
for Android but just finding a hard-on
to the bomb yeh with two incredible
kills they're picking up the AWP and a
bomb plant will be huge on top of this
surely not surely he's not able to pull
this one beat you off low HP 12 health
we know Nate's were you coming from
behind yeah let's get aggressive
somewhere
you sit away to talk no work oh the
missed shot he's got the first and the
second yeh punishes Pig what an
incredible sequence phase right now
taking nothing for granted here they're
gonna make him go deep for the bomb and
no they have the advantage and they know
that he has to plot made enough to do
too much oh my god opportunity there
Nico didn't land a single bullet you
can't say that every day goes down to
two and off my sir critically weak as
well we know how good he is there's a
chance here now
he tries desperately to make this one
work they cannot allow this round to go
sour still trying to find those players
desperate it's so difficult to try to
isolate them but he has time or we fight
another one that's all of us are dead
one more to go rain it's got a beagle
what it does it's sunny that is
incredible
the patience and the focus that's
absolutely what mousesports needed chunk
quick here with the AWP they make around
the corner but that's the bomb drop that
he's looking for a bit more two on one
next to it he's gotta be careful he's
double scoped up there looking for the
kills still 50 seconds on the clock so
they comes bigger with a long time to
recover this bomb he rushes through he
gets the one she said 75 she actually
makes it back around the corner and he's
gonna go backward that bumpers they're
always gone make sure it how does he do
that Beltre good position to be in
because coming to connector he can
control with the boxes he doesn't quite
get ready for a Tico's presents a palace
which is a little bit late to be fair
could have saved his teammates had to
get that kill a little bit sooner
raucous mate epic eco still pulls off
against somebody enough to ladder down
it again it's a very awkward position
for Dini and the ego just dominates him
he's now gotten three kills and one more
to find 15 seconds is too big a problem
calm down in front of them all talk will
certainly keep the defense away and hold
so that they can't quite see him pick up
the ball I thought Nieto was gonna be
dead they're thought expert would read
leave yours now gonna have a bomb went
down in the nick of time and he could
still pull this back this is the mid
round stuff we're talking about it might
not be team play this time it's
individual heroics what a shot as he
just destroys ex curat existence is
completely exposed there and death will
take it down and I said number one from
Suzanne this is falling apart very
quickly the dream is collapsing and
socks is a linen on one vs. four how
many kills as you could put as a player
on depo he's got so much to do the smoke
inside the transfer is there it could
jump on the high ground does he focus on
the pump and still bring the fuse oh my
god shocks is going nuclear
he's got three kills on CTools out is as
he wasted enough time though oh he has
this one around that's ridiculous shocks
how on earth have you done max seems
Tyler will not expecting that additional
grade on banana that's a nice shot from
somebody he's so smart with these plays
and now he's made it a winnable route
yes is incredible a real chance here
answer and still Oh left the greatest
money utility somebody with 51 HP so it
could be worse he's looking for the
flying
run all the way around that is insane no
idea what's going on could you imagine
they had no kit could you imagine that's
insane I have never seen that one in
photo that's a mirage where is it oh my
oh my god think God's name is happening
in this game that was completely
unreasonable especially that second kill
you gonna see a lot of replays of that
ladies and gentlemen get right now the
bomb punt and they are miles away
puts the bomb down then runs back to
middle again a very very hard for us
rather to read instant kill on me you
scan now the pocket does it be Venice
continuing on a Greek triple for him and
simple 46 health up on the hike around
that bomb ticking away they need to
defuse it at some point simple just
waiting for them and now they're finally
gonna try and go for it he needs one
good headshot they're trying to stop it
one second oh my god he actually gets
the kill and that's it 16 to 6 backside
of banana crush wants to work in that
direction and oh my goodness 30 degree
window dragon how did that miss that
shaved his pubic hair so close to his
heart forget to kill G as he walks
through and inside of the smoke fanatic
find 11 oh my goodness 417 H people need
to peak until he oh he's quite a
fountain gotta stay alive now thoughts
another fountain and that was the one
versus two no smoke for grave planting
two orders of coffins
that's that go and twist come in from
the same position that they have to win
this clutch dance team liquid need to
win this clutch the clave he is ready to
spoil their day as they move in that's
right oh that is big that's such a big
deal 14 HP what a beautiful connection
there through the coffins is clave
repositions taco go for the
or we can't do it though now things get
interesting trying to actually fake for
a flash potentially a slave repositions
here just toying with twist he knows he
can't take a fight he just has to
confuse him and make it really difficult
for twist to find the fraggin some way
clave is playing the mind game the twist
he tries to go on boys go for the whole
clave says no if he drops the clave they
might just run out of time and cleave
it's gonna get us up to ten seconds now
the free in CT spawn you only want to
kill you it the bombs drop they can't
get the bombs out in front in time -
Brutus has to say there's no way oh just
in the last millisecond they put down
that farm Dupree he knew we have to stay
hidden there's a very good chance that
would never work in now how does he get
back into this one they have a Molotov
as well ranae's gonna land on him spring
right from taking down clay oh sorry not
pan at all
now I'm gonna follow up he has no smoke
this is incredibly tricky and he's gonna
tap tap on just holding it down all of
waiting on the other side one more
second and Caprice gonna get the shot
and he should have the time as well TV
views on one on two early on to get
Australis on the board that is just a
very difficult to do it really sabotage
their own finances here liquid still
have a chance though at least out of
nowhere it's now a 2 vs. 1 and twist is
certainly capable winning these sort of
rounds what will be planted but he is so
aggressive man he's my buddy finalist
kill he's got to be loaded it's all
falling apart twist isolating the corner
still making this work it'll be
absolutely fantastic
he's done it
a twist indeed because liquid are gonna
pick up around they had no business
winning then that looks like it could be
it because electronic he's one be three
how can he do this
oh one more to go though bomb planted
you'll quickly apply the pressure
tapping on that one as he moves forward
through the door trying to guess but
it's gonna be made very difficult he's
he's up against device and he's going
for Mahal by electronic that's the plane
are that you needed to get back in
that's the kind of brain you want to see
from them okay so it's one thing to
clutch when your entire team is dead and
you basically have no choice it's
another entirely to turn to your squad
and say hold my beer here are the best
aces from one
it's where the plush pillows are the
silk robes the slippers the massage oil
I kept trying to give himself a gap and
that's going to work absolute wonders
they can do this is he gonna trade fast
enough
no no he isn't oh that's disgusting that
is absolutely disgusting to make Sakura
another headshot to finish off the job
or another place as far as 5/7 and or a
smoke for company it can be super
powerful we've got Yugi on the side of
the USB and gave them the normal spot
that's a very nice shot from here your
London gain doing this big monstrous
this case as well that was nasty from
spot to finish that was absolutely
disgusting
he'll race is running a clock down and
trying to exhaust liquid okay leash
that's a nice one tuck from you lovely
for them even liquid have to only two
players in the B bomb site so maybe
there's a chance it but it's gonna be
very difficult and that's already what
Alicia's going to town oh my god is just
crushed everyone on the entire team two
kills are massive mi be our new the
situation when aggressive as a result
balanced rotated around bringing the are
pit slowly yeah they line up they make
it all too easy I thought he might get
away with waters they were searching
inside of the site but round all but
done surely Shazam left 423 they know
exactly where he is what a way to steal
it back first in five and they keep all
five alive bowler driving in the chaos
Ave that mullet over the bottom was the
promo to see T's ours thrown by the
terrorists who all got caught up and
they go down one by one
you can't take anything away those
before
who nails every single shop he does such
a good job that these sump pumps out
with the AWP finishing things off for
the a K but Jessica was well toward
ventures yet to move nails now no
mistake about a topcoat I know where I
can start this off with an ace just
proud sprawling for it Peak with the AWP
and I'll try to trade him out and grin
gain ground and hello there's electronic
or there's the flash to confirm
information and that's one way to do it
oh my god it's a massacre James poor
players dead immediately off the back of
one sprayed to do what he can that's
gonna be frustrating as well all your
teammates dead that's one way to do it
Gordon so much super cute guys there
were so many sick plays from this past
major we couldn't put them all into neat
little categories so here's a section
we're calling the best of the rest of
nutty plays from the major this should
be very easy threesome
one whereas the trade was the tray
there's no trade he's a shuts it all
down oh just got a clinical clean from
ISA I'd love to see it and that is an
even nicer way to finish it off and this
is anticipation by coldzera they've got
at any contact toward that boiler
position with two players playing that
far forward they start the rotation
early and they're going to go for the
flank this is full commitment from
complexity no other options and from
straight up on on here fires directly
down they got walked inside of the smoky
cold
the pistol it's gone from bad to worse
another clean sweep firm IBR two on four
now they've got a big chance right now
on the fees side maybe they can bring
this into overtime
taking down the vise no scoped from that
Scout dropping him and now it's all
under pre-warn the vs. for quick cover
oh my god and he wants to continue just
needs a little bit more no chance for
real oh now they almost lined up and
he's got another one this cannot be true
by the way he's down the raid bus walls
and all of mice they're gonna bring it
to round number 13
what is this game seems absolutely
impossible fallen ready for this flank
buddy gets on the face it's wobbly god
what just happened sit mix around the
corner notice
swings almost doubles up up two players
here the Scout has got a soul my word
device that's disgusting
three quills three kills and quick
secession no hoping for the timing but
it isn't working now a bunch of people
coming in for the event three of them
trying to retake here he's against one a
great oh this is beautiful
what are you supposed to do we didn't
get to see that one a one time this is
amazing that is so hard to do with so
many different targets shooting at you
all three just the patience the
mechanical aim comes into play there's
the pawn flash there's the swing out and
they've got one falling us to back away
but they want to go back to the board
push sticking around in the rouging
despite falling that football whatever
can't handle it either
there's nothing pouncing at the right
moment
[Music]
is set up and a half you know you put
that down on paper and you think this is
how it's probably gonna work out the
chances that it actually does live with
a server and his mentioning the
semi-finals very very slim beautiful
counter try that's what simple said that
he wanted bomb that's a great setup
smear playing it slow and I can see mace
to run distraction gets one back out of
it at least loads of jumping nice one
type from him and there's one more that
is this last thing mr. Butterfield and
they're gonna go for that beef play it
was so successful in regulation dismiss
had a body bought played before it
didn't work
he's got to make it better this time
that is way better here Christmas gets
the fall week as a hope for that is
incredible
not the equipment of choice thanks for
the managers Nikola Wayne could put you
the next heart attack here oh yeah
Seward as well that's so ridiculous I
mean obviously there's not a great
chance of winning I think the tough part
is God beat cannot be aggressive Oh put
a sneaky bastard he's lever girl just
throw it away the m-40 knows there's no
way you can save it so they're gonna be
so upset yeah that their sort of thing
yeah I'm gonna pick up the simple but
I'm not the quartic God that is the
genius he will be taken down very
quickly automatic back on one but it's
up to one thing so he wasn't having the
best time of it but he is having a
fantastic day phenomenal they're from
bonding to end things on the first hop
what is left
oh no the grenade that might be a
record-setting one that officials for
forty plus damage on all of them it's
done and it's over let's call the game
someone throw in the towel deliver some
headshots
taco in that white mark early landing
all the head sauce backlight with three
in a row and how traces will not be
getting the second pistol phenomenal
performance by a fly continues to shine
really impressive is before when so far
he is looking like he's in championship
former at this stage Oh
goodness he's just so critical calm the
one-way zoo spams it but furnace at
Flint he doesn't that night is just
ready and waiting he wants more than the
single one he's gonna be pushing up the
flashbang as in his eyes still fallen
getting a kill and he's just waiting for
it for a new 22nd so you want to play
for time here you're gonna finally tip
it away in the pond does not get planted
you needed a couple of more seconds
there's through trouble one walk but
then the seconds left and it's a
one-on-one instant headshot with that
eagle short kill potential at any range
as strong as it is bouncy stop there
from the mat as he falls back to safety
but device is not one of these players
there's two up we go and there's number
three hollows use I succeeded played
Smith's left on it I'm not sure if he
did na'vi don't expect this the problem
is even if I kill this is a lot of
information they've got is you take it
out okay guys that's it for the best of
the face at London major now if you did
enjoy this video drop a like drop a
comment and subscribe to the channel
that's what I call a YouTube ace and if
you're still jonesing for that major
content well in less than 24 hours we
are dropping the best fails and funny
moments from this past major I'll see
you then
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]